new video appears to show Russia's
Flagship Cruiser the 43 year old
mosquevar or Moscow shortly before she
sank in the Black Sea on April the 14th
but what actually happened to the Aged
mosque VAR this image offers clues in
clear distress and listing heavily
Portside the mosquev appears to be
burning internally with smoke billowing
from portholes there are signs of Hull
damage life rafts are missing the
helicopter doors are open while a rescue
ship alongside sprays water jets
Ukraine claims it fired land-based
Neptune missiles that struck the cruiser
off the coast of Odessa Russia says only
that there was a fire on board and that
she sank in choppy Waters while under
tow back to Port
yet the waters here are calm and the
mosqueva is not under Tow and perhaps
most importantly the fire at BS have
broken up just ahead of its air defense
missiles and just behind its
surface-to-surface missiles so if at
some point after the imagery was taken
uh either of those systems ignited that
would have likely caused a much larger
explosion that would have made the ship
effectively unsalvageable so it's
undoubtedly a ship in distress and very
much consistent with the ship that has
been subject to a successful cruise
missiles right
also uncertain is the fate of the
moskvaz crew as many as 500 strong on
Saturday Russian defense Ministry
pictures showed the commander-in-chief
of the Navy meeting the ship's crew in
the Crimean Port of sevastopol
only around a hundred men are present
Russia has not confirmed any casualties
but there are reports of social media
posts by relatives announcing the death
of loved ones on board posts that were
later deleted
in the opening salvos of Russia's
Invasion the mosque VAR played a major
part foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Ted border guards on Snake Island in
Ukrainian Waters and ordered them to
surrender
the incident and their colorful response
became an emblem of Ukrainian resistance
the sunken moskvah almost two months
later is now emblematic of something
else not just one of the most
significant losses in recent Naval
History but assigned to many as well
that Ukraine's resistance is working
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera